[Applause]
[Music]
thanks andrea first of all this the
first time I speak Italian so if
there is a bit strange forgive me try
with the messaging and the evolution of google
that I put people the
notification system we launched in 2010
in
2014 and then in 2015 he worked with
mozilla and chrome to create a
standard for bringing notifications to the
web.The standard is called white bush and
allows browsers to behave a bit
like phones if, for example, you use
a google plus facebook partner system and
you don't have the page open but someone
writes a comment on your
chrome or firefox page michael also opens
a window saying there was a no  tify
click open the page to comment
use calm yes it is very simple
this is an example on android
add in the poster of your
service and after that do a month
jersey how it works it is very simple the
phone to a
persistent connection with with the  google server
and when the message arrives the
cole messaging code that was written on the
play services sends a broadcast time
this code in your application
is followed make you skull messaging is
integrated not only with function evening
this to do well but mainly with
fire band  analytics this allows you
to send notifications to specific groups
of your users for example if you
want to send a physical one who
has bought at least once in
your application you can do it
through analytics there is also a
user interface that allows you to
do it in the console  far
west notifications are very important in
especially for the hagema ring  n if
users stop using your
application send a notification the
chances of users going back to using
your application are very high
alibaba is one of the largest services
in china as they say once they have
implemented fibers for the web they have
had  a 400 percent increase
in rennes gage lies their users while it
is an Indian ecommerce and uses analytics and
cloud messaging to report users
who have purchased have placed
products in their cart but have not
completed the track using
notifications with analytics they have
increased by  300 per cent of the
final purchases then let's talk about
analytics how these
groups we call audience are created to use
analytics it is very simple relatives
asti that you put it in your
application without writing lines of
code analysis begins to generate the 20
and the garlin in the system  so if you
go to the console the first thing you
see without doing anything
are there  a demographic how many users
use your application in which countries
which language they use ages what type of
operating system they use type of
phone
the app store etc. also tells you
how many people continue to use
your application how much time they
spend in your application and
how long you stay  gaining this by
default
then you can add other events that
are predefined and based on the type of
your application there are different
types of events if for example you have a
commerce application these are
predefined examples that arrive so
if you remember the example of
send notification and those who have
made a purchase
you can use flashlight ecommerce and
target those users who end up in
this audience and obviously you can
add the twenty custom
for example if your signup the
registration button occurs on the
third screen of the application you can
create an audience by telling everyone
who clicks  on the
registration button but have not completed it
all farbe services are integrated with
each other and all use analytics one of the
most important cyclamen and services and
extreme faib con fei which allows you to
change the system in which
the application works in  based on the
hateful they are practically a series of
variables that you put in the code
you can change in real time on the cloud
and assign certain segments to users
for example if you notice that the
register button on the third screen
works very well in Italy but does not
work in California you can  change
for American users and put it for
example in the first screen works
as a kind of ebit a sting these
are friends who have a
recipe application and have seen that the
conversion in half of 200 percent
simply by changing the
initial image of the  application and saying if
you are Italian and we put a plate of
pasta with tomato sauce and if you are Japanese we
put it  ono a tray of suu kyi other
Japanese konami and gygax have done in
a very interesting experiment
and depending on the audience they have
increased or decreased the
frequency level of the display ads and the
final result is that they have had a revenue of
20 percent  higher than the previous one and
as I said that as Andrea explained, not
only the farbe services are intrigued
integrated with each other but they are
also integrated with google through at this
moment in fact now you
can export all the
analytics data and then do the  rest what
you want you can take them to
machine learning ways export to trici
anything else
in this example practically make one
those on making an
ascending list of users of your
android and ios applications by country
on drugs are like you seen all  'I start
many services 1 one last that
we launched two months ago and google to the
files for which automatically tells you
how many  tence there is between one screen
of your application and
also in this way you can connect it
remotely with fei and say if you are in india
of screen 23 there is a
higher latency than america maybe you can
activate an hourglass something that
improves the  'input for users if you are
interested in knowing everything else there is fire
and bass point google.com and you will find
all the applications all the services
we have launched
[Applause]
thanks I only allow myself to
add just one thing about
just how much  said because we have seen
how it is possible from fer bass to export
data undergoing queries and this enables a
long series of features because in addition
to the nichetti ice vacillates that we have
shown you in the slide in a few slides ago
in practice you also have the possibility of
using tensor flow manager on  cloud
machine learning therefore starting from
all the data that are exported to you from
fair bass starting from all the
information you collect about
users
you have the possibility to launch
presumably supervisor
machine learning algorithms that allow you, for
example, to categorize users and even
more so if you are increasingly
able to offer relevant content
than the user himself then the
call functions create a very
nice bridge  with nichetti ice jaws but
also fire besco the
automatic export features on
we have here the engineers stop you
so we deliberately have this for
now so
go big
the question is I repeat it for the
microphone and I don't know if you all know but a few months
ago we have  acquired fabric from twitter
of our confirmation group now
say in english work on line we are
working a lot with the group
to have these crash
litex integrations created with files and what can i say
that the two products will be merged and will
take the best of  two in the suite to
do well
pro saleh I want to ask a question
because in reality I don't  n I am
android developer but they interact
with the android developer who are
using the tool does airbase it is
actually I have an application that is on the
group on google cloud cloud platfond and
projects in various ways on the cloud
platform that does nothing but
generate notifications such as  you have mentioned
through file based to devices
so the interaction takes place between the device
and my software the hiatus on the platform
but from what I seemed to understand
the original idea of doing well is ac
ually starting from the device towards an example of th
database that has made available
to do bass eventually make a
stream queried as you said
in reality what we are doing
is the exact opposite of what you
have done as an example the question is
really of the question and the error is
design  ours in using
this tool in this way or in
reality it is missing because the discourse that
in the practical then my web
software web platform does not  it does not have a
file based kay s not done because it makes
adverse curl calls faib and towards fire
bass which has its bees rightly to
send notifications and given a file
based lidi a jason content to be sent to the
device
us in fact  to date we use to be able
to practically do a
multi device communication without worrying about the
device that receives so much we do not see
the file based device and it ends there
for our web platform there is
no one in reality
you can use it would save all the levels
our services or at least
we try to get to that level
have a typical res and that can be
used exactly as you do
or we have admin asti that for some
of the services that simplify life in
certain languages you think of java python I nev
r come as you want to use  serv
when you love me hook to your answer
ad minas decay for java what it
is
rogers java python in goal
for example for database will choose
all and  four are the various languages
ich we generate the albumin stick hyper v sit
ates in a server you want to try one of these
four languages then you can do it through our
dynastic for which it connects
use off the ventila
ion die farbe soft automatical
y you do not
ave to create keys to  managing them
then in practice should find a
microsoft vis that exploits this genie
of cai who then excommunicates himself with my
software which instead has a whole other
development logic that is fine thanks
a lot
ok hi my name is luigi a
quick information among the various pious  I have seen there
are all the cars I use to do beautiful there is
also a beautiful example for
payments with strikes with ep haiti stripe
and so on
there will then be some plateaus that is you
intend to develop ad hoc ep ai
for mobile wounding for  the
payment with google floor anything else
yes there is a team in our group that
dedicated to the theme ayachi the china and various
and pious and such
as you know how to do the m  ese it started
like in 2015
I launched far west 2.0 and
so what they are trying to
do is create the various services have
a common interface to the various
admin asti ideas you have for everyone and then we
start adding plans for
other services
new  york well then i'm a novice
of grasshopper i started studying it a
couple of weeks ago i created a
private area that is based on a use of
data in fire bass the difficulty i am
encountering is to go and do the
classic select  that could be done
with a sql language in fire weight
or go to search if in the
database in fire boss
there is a certain value l if there was
some advice
always in the database database and
never tried both you there is an interface
and the  he had the database he should
do at your home
after the evening can he show it
ok thank you too I don't know
very well he does bass so I start
thinking about a somewhat generic case a
gen scenario  erico imagine we have
an application that already has a
large file based database somehow it
must be integrated into this, that is, in this
scheme in which it is actually
placed side by side with the application database in
order to offer those features we
have seen today what is the scenario
more or less  to see in these cases
this is a common case because
unless you are a start up that starts
with firewalls some of the services are
arrow and difficult to move a whole
for this reason that we are creating the reste
dpa and products as functions you can
connect the  your database with functions
and do the same things that seen
when yours from base to one
write a post in Viterbo it connects
French then send km gen for the rest
all the other things it has seen then
the application p ai are extended
o  replaced by this this new
layer we were talking about one of the
main ideas of Chinese fans exactly
connect the various services and call them the
equal serv  and it can be from yours but it can
also be a database of another
public provider side and it acts as a
glue for these services
thanks in this case a last
question
thanks
[Applause]